here i didn't know what to bring you so
i just got some magazines and lipstick
woman stuff thanks all my parents got me
was that
okay well i'm not very good at visiting
people in hospitals
so i'm going to go hey
if you see andy will you not tell him
i'm here okay
because of what happened i don't want
him to think stop don't want to know
the less i know about other people's
affairs the happier i
am i'm not interested in caring about
people
i once worked with a guy for three years
and never learned his name
best friend i ever had
we still never talk sometimes fire fire
fire
what where in my belly because the
24-hour pawnee cares diabetes telethon
starts tonight goody let us know how it
went
when he finds out what grizzle is doing
he's going to lose
his mind
i have no reaction to this what i do not
pass judgment on the workings of private
businesses i just build their buildings
and frankly if people are foolish enough
to carry around a doodad that lets
grizzle track their every move
this is what they get
third time today
that's a good shoeshine
um
what the [ __ ] man i i don't know
what happened frankly
i emitted a noise the noise was
involuntary
sometimes a sound is just a sound you
know
run run wake up
ron wake up it's leslie
are you having a bad dream no i suffer
from a disorder called sleep fighting
must be terrible only when i'm losing
look i'm freaking out okay
tom is not here and he's got debt left
[ __ ] and i have three hours to fill
i'm sure you'll figure something out
don't go back to sleep okay i need you
to wake up
ron come on help me attaboy
i am only here because i owe leslie a
thousand favors
i'm not big on charities give a man a
fish
and you feed him for a day don't teach a
man to fish
and you feed yourself he's a grown man
fishing's not that hard well i've made a
little progress
i'm up to four seconds with april hey
april
i was looking to get some new music and
i was wondering if you could recommend
anything
the internet i really like your haircut
where'd you get it
prison how's your sister doing she has
the shingles who's your favorite
character on sex in the city
alf and nine seconds with ron
you're stranded on a desert island what
is the one thing that you bring with you
silence
is leslie here oh man i am so
tired i took a half shift at the
hospital last night
and i had this really weird patient
weird how i probably shouldn't talk
about as one of the grossest things i've
ever seen
talk well this guy came in he got his
hand stuck in a pringles can
and he tried to cut himself out what
kind of blade did he use
uh three and a half inch serrated
buckets of blood he passed out over his
arm and slumped onto the floor
to the bone boncho very good question
april answer her
yeah the bone showed everyone in the
universe
loves a gross medical story boom i win
and so when i finally cleaned up the
vomit i found the toe
i forgot about the towel so did we crazy
right that story is awesome
indeed thank you for sharing jenny
ann was getting a little chummy when
people get too chummy with me
i like to call them by the wrong name to
let them know i don't really care about
them
that's a genius move thank you you're
welcome
lester
i'd like to object again to being
brought here against my will
okay i'm just gonna double-check your
form here ron you redacted all the
information i answered some of them
for date of birth you wrote springtime
which is true
everything you write down is
confidential we need you to give real
answers
fine how many drinks of alcohol do you
consume a week
one that's it one drink one shelf
do you exercise yes lovemaking and
woodworking
do you have any history of mental
illness in your family i have an uncle
who does
yoga allergies cowardice and weak-willed
men
and hazelnuts sexual history epic
and private okay i'm gonna go get your
doctor
he's a rude brash jerk you'll love him
ron you have to help me chris is making
me do some stupid management training
leadership course
can you get me out of it yes normally
if given a choice between doing
something and nothing i choose to do
nothing
but i will do something if it helps
someone else do nothing i'd work all
night
if it meant nothing got done can you
guys just figure out which way is better
and tell me so we can leave
thank you for your input april but the
ketumps requires that we follow a very
specific syllabus you're not being very
inclusive chris
i feel like my input isn't being
appreciated you've killed my spirit
my spirit blood is on your hands
my god i've taught you so much already
ron i propose a challenge to see whose
motivational methods
are more effective challenge accepted i
don't want to seem overdramatic
but this is literally a battle for april
soul
i don't want to seem over-dramatic but i
don't really care what happens here
if any of you need anything at all
too bad deal with your problems
yourselves like adults
i'll be in my office waiting for tammy
juan you want me to find her
there's no need she'll find me she has
the tracking ability
and body odor of a bloodhound
got a second box of donuts if anybody
what the is this this mr director
is your new desk okay this desk is the
epitome
of the swedish concept of yamsteldak or
equality imagine someone needs your
attention somebody say my name
chris swivel what is jerry
you told me to say your name and you did
a great job superstar
someone else say something you look like
a freak swivel
april that is not a very good attitude i
will keep my eye on you
from my circular desk where i can see
everything tiny swivel
see how it works what about my office
and its many walls that becomes a new
public waiting room
and we got rid of that giant pillar that
was in front of your door i loved that
pillar
it made it really annoying to stand in
my doorway excuse me
there's a sign at ramps at park that
says do not drink the sprinkler water
so i made sun tea with it and now i have
an infection
sir sir are are
are you listening to me sir sir i'm
talking to you
sir sir are you aware
that there is waste in your water system
you